The late 19th century gave us the installment, Plan-A-Way, to sell encyclopedias to families who couldn't afford them all at once,
one volume at a time, month after month, until the shelves sagged under the weight of half-finished knowledge and the ledger never closed.
And now, we just virtualized the whole thing.
Call it what it is, the subscription trap.
It's the financial equivalent of the silent treatment.
You forget you even signed up, but every 30 days, it reminds you like a creditor at the gate of Fleet Prison.
Only this one doesn't care about silk waistcoats.
It just wants payment.
And if you don't give it, well, that's on you.
You're the one who failed to maximize your potential access.
Most people start with a free trial.
The maven starts with the sunk cost.
Hand over that credit card, and suddenly you've made an investment.
Not in the service, not in the value, just in the idea of it.
Canceling feels like admitting you wasted money.
Like you didn't get your money's worth.
So you keep paying even as the app gathers dust on your phone.
Here's how it works.
First, there's the just-in-case reframe.
Subscribe to the Niche Knowledge app, the advanced productivity tool because what if, someday, you might need it.
The Premium Weather app, because why not?
Now your bank statement is a symphony of the city's noise, and you can't tune it out.
You're paying for potential, not progress.
Then there's the annual trap.
Save 20% by locking yourself in for a year.
It's the financial version of staying in a relationship because you've already paid for the honeymoon.
12 months of commitment, no questions asked.
And the forgotten audit?
Never check your active subscriptions.
If an email says your subscription renewed, delete it.
Don't engage.
This is avoidance coping on a budgetary scale, ignoring the slow leak until the dam breaks.
Finally, there's the data hoarding premium.
Pay for extra storage for your 50,000 unorganized photos.
Why delete them?
Why clean up?
Just keep paying to preserve the mess.
That way, you never have to face the audit.
And that's the point.
The subscription trap turns you into a human utility.
Always on, never used.
A life of a thousand small, invisible holes.
Energy and wealth draining into the void.
Drop by drop, month by month.
Consider the unused gym membership.
You pay for the potential of health, but you master the art of sitting still.
Guilt and bankruptcy, hand in hand.
A masterpiece of the system.
A subscription is a promise you made to a version of yourself that no longer exists.
And yet, you keep the promise.